Bill Gates criticized project loom
saying when you're dying of malaria I
suppose you'll look up and see that
balloon and I'm not sure how it will
help you have you heard from Bill and
how do you respond to that yeah I mean
bill and I have had a few conversations
about this and and other things that
we've worked on together and you know I
think the reality is that people need a
lot of things in order to have good
lives right when health is certainly
extremely important right and we've done
a number of things at Facebook to help
improve global health and and work in
that area and I'm excited to do more
there too but the reality is that it's
not an either/or right when people need
to be healthy and to have the Internet
as a backbone to connect them to the
whole global economy the internet
creates jobs it actually is one of the
things that facilitates health so for
example in the most recent Ebola
outbreak one of the things that Facebook
tried to do was we asked a bunch of
folks who were involved in in containing
the outbreak you know what can we do to
help and the number one thing that they
said is help us get connectivity because
we need to be able to wire up all these
different Ebola treatment units to make
it so that we can coordinate the
response and that people know and can
count the people who've come into
contact with with folks who have Ebola
so it ends up being important it's not
an either/or and you know I'm certainly
not here saying that that connectivity
is more important than health I mean
that would be ridiculous but I hope that
we can help out with all these things
over time